[Music]
you're struggling with like erections or
she is not interested in sex she's not
interested in sex at all like she says
there are more than more than one way to
express making love you know you don't
need to have sex to make love and I'm
like well you kind of
[Music]
do well good morning good afternoon and
good night I'm John donon with the Dr
John delone show show about your mental
health your emotional health your
marriage your kids whatever is going on
in your world may not know the answer
but I promise I'll sit with you and we
will figure it out for two decades um
I've been sitting with people I got a
couple of phds and I'll be the first to
tell you I don't know but I know this I
know how to sit with hurting people and
figure out what's the next right move or
scared people or people who are just out
of options or clueless and um if you you
want to be on the show I'd love to have
you go to John
del.
askas or go give me a buzz at 1844 693
3291 it's 1844 693
3291 we're heading into the Christmas
season so if you have not got your
questions for humans Christmas edition
they sold out like instantly last year
we've ordered a whole bunch more and
they're already leaving the shop like
who Let The Dogs Out whooo Kelly let's
do one all right this is a good one to
start the season okay when should you
put Christmas decorations up and when
should you take them down oh gez when do
you think um I like to have mine up I
usually put them up the week before
Thanksgiving because we travel for
Thanksgiving and I like them when we
come home from Thanksgiving it's on
Christmas is on and then I usually take
them down the week the week after New
Years
okay Jenna you're all listen if I wasn't
moving houses is in a week my Christmas
decorations would already be up November
1st listen Halloween's over I take down
the Halloween decorations I put up the
Christmas and I'll leave them up
probably
until maybe mid January to end of
January by February they're down but I'd
like good couple I like a good couple
months listen Christmas is a season it
makes me happy I love the lights boo on
your happiness there's rules to this no
there are no rules There Are Rules my
happiness is what matters I like to put
my Christmas decoration up whenever my
wife says we're going to put these up
now and I say that sounds
incredible that's pretty much my rule do
yall do it before Thanksgiving or is it
after
um I'm going to put this in my husband
of the Year application I have no idea I
don't know that there's a set thing I
think it's just like hey there's a
weekend and my wife's like yeah we're
doing that this weekend and I'll say
that sounds awesome yeah ours ends up
that way and sometimes it might be two
weeks before Thanksgiving because the
week before we have something to do or
and also I will say because we had such
a crap year last year Christmas sucked
from beginning to end so even my
husband's like this year we're going
early and yeah we're Christmas in all
the way through it yeah so we're
actually I've talked about doing them
this coming weekend and Jenna when's
your baby due
February so is it your your kids just
going to be born into Christmas Even
though it's I said they'll be down
before February a 9month pregnant I'm
not taking him down will take him down
you kidding me no no no no I will tell
him there's the Box put them in there
put them in the garage I don't say this
very often but I think with all of my
heart men should I'd have a vote on this
just move on I know that's not Kosher
but why would you
care because it's your house and your
family H that's where you wrong it is
your house and your family no but I mean
we just work here you come from your own
traditions of your own house of your own
family that make the holiday season I
have I have one weird thing about it
this is one weird thing I don't like
Christmas ornaments and stuff going up
on the tree without everybody there I
have a weird thing about that we're big
about that everybody even I mean one
year my wife did it with the two kids
with and but I she was helping out I was
doing something I was out of town I came
in and I was devastated she was she felt
so bad but yeah everybody has to do the
tree I like everybody in there and then
U my kids all put all the decorations in
one area so then when they go to bed I
redo the tree but I just great everybody
has to be there to do the tree no
question I love that yeah we have a
certain movie we watch while we do it
we're very yeah that's one of the things
that Reed re about that there's certain
things that have to happen hey by the
way huge news totally unrelated to what
we're talking about um this weekend I
was getting some more tattoos done and
the woman who does my tattoos said she
would come up to the studio and we'll do
it live do what live your tattoo and
I'll pay for it
tada big fat nope on that it's it's I
have the yes card it's going to be a yes
so that's questions for humans go to
john.com yes cards for that go to
john.com and um you'll be entered into a
drawing to get to pick what Kelly's
tattoo is going to be and we're going to
record it here in the office and it's
going to be incredible all right let's
go out to Idaho and talk to Mike Mike
Mike Mike Mike what's up dude howy uh
not much just taking a break from work
to talk to you guys very cool man I'm
glad you called dude what's up um yeah
well I uh so I want to start this off
with I love my family and I love my wife
and I know she loves me um but I'm gonna
I'm gonna kind of just dump some stuff
on you and then we'll see where we go
from there bring it um so we have a we
have a 15-month-old son and another one
on the way and um you know we we've been
together for God going on six years now
and um you know we're we're pretty
passionate about each other we're very
aligned value wise very faithful people
but um you know the one area where we we
have some issues is uh the bedroom and
you know even when she's not pregnant
like I'm struggling to be intimate with
my wife and um you know know be more
specific struggling to be intimate
you're struggling with like erections or
she is not
no she's not interested in sex at all
like she says there are more than more
than one way to express making love and
you know you don't need to have sex to
make love and I'm like well you kind of
do I you know and and she says if you
did more romantic things for me you know
it would it would make a difference with
regards to how often we have sex and
like I try and make advances on her and
she like swats me away and there's more
to it than that like you know I know
she's become kind of insecure since
we've been together and there's some
stuff going on with like her childhood
and her parents
and be specific so I you you you threw a
little piece out that I've got um some
opinions on but there sounds like
there's a bigger Pi well actually let's
do this let's approach step one and then
I want to dig into the other stuff so
step
one I
think the idea that women have a lower
sex Drive than men is an absolute myth
it's not real it's not true or that
women have something called a sex drive
which is a myth that and it is just male
sex drive light right none of that is
true if you look at the literature and
you look at um the studies done what is
true is sex and desire how those things
are all woven together um think of it as
um this comes straight from Dr Emily
nagy's work um I recommend your wife
read a book um called come as you are it
is incredible it's got a I probably
wouldn't have made that cover but the um
book is
extraordinary um and it's just a master
class of all the things
that millions and millions of women
didn't get I also think it's a good read
for men too but it's written to women
about women's health and women's sexual
health but here's how what she describes
it she kind of pulls apart the myth of
sex drive and instead paints a picture
that sex is a series or desire is a
series of breaks and gas
pedals and if you think of it that
way for you gas pedals might be a wink
it might be just thinking of your wife
it might be um somebody attractive walks
by you at work and suddenly you're like
like oh this is happening tonight right
your whole life is gas pedals for other
people there might their environment
might be a bunch of breaks got to make
sure the kid is doing this I've got to
make sure um this kid is fed I got to
make sure I'm healthy I got to go for my
walk I gotta make sure the dishes it up
because I want to be a good wife and I
have this picture of what wife looks
like and my husband and I've have never
talked about it and then you come home
and you start pawing at her or doing you
bring home a
flower you might think you are being
romantic here's your gesture and that
might have nothing to do with her brakes
and gas
pedals and so where I see people miss
each other all the time is she says I
need you to be more affectionate if you
were more
affectionate then I would want to have
sex more and you go into your toolbox of
affectionate that is probably a mix
of and I'm just not pointing at you I'm
say I'm speaking you as males in general
okay a mix of pornography a mix of
conversations you've had maybe a couple
of old girlfriends and just
some
imagination and you dip into that
toolkit and you're like all right
affection here we come and maybe your
mom made you want to watch a Hallmark
movie once and that Guy brought flowers
and you're like all right that sounds
cool and what you do is you miss the
whole boat and what I've seen couples
dramatically turn their sex lives around
by Simply Having the conversation about
gas pedals and
brakes and I'll just give you a story
from my own house I really took it
personally that my
wife had to have the kitchen
clean before anything could
happen and I put the math in my head
that she thought a clean kitchen was
more valuable than smoke show McGee over
here come to find out she had some
stories in her head about what a good
wife was and what a homemaker supposed
to do and all this this baggage she was
carrying around I had no IDE she was
carrying around and so once we sat down
and talked it
through dude you know what I love doing
now the
dishes right I I like things that I
never would have assumed are about
affection or about you see me and or
help with bed times or take care of the
dogs or whatever the things are right so
there's that's a whole thing that is
worthy of a conversation that sit on and
have what does affection mean to
you and you're going to be probably
shocked that it has very little to do
with touching and looking and all that
stuff it has to do with an environment
right we we we've definitely had those
conversations and her ideas of romance
are like you know us taking the truck
out and looking at the stars yep have
you tried that you know um you know it's
funny she's told me that since day one
we've never done it just for whatever
reason I don't want to do it bro I I she
gave you the road map I know I know that
one that one's totally on me I've
definitely made mistakes you're like one
of the few that know what to do
unbelievable can't believe you're
calling me all right so tell me about
the other stuff about family stuff and
childhood trauma well so the the other
thing is she she she's told me this
repeatedly she knew I was making this
this call okay and um she said I can't
keep a secret for my life and she's like
uh she said she hates sex like
vehemently even when we were having sex
a lot uh before we were married um you
know she said I I've never enjoyed it I
only did it because of you and because I
love you and I think that has a lot to
do with I mean I'm the only sexual
partner she's ever had I've had more
than one uh prior to us being married
and then um you know also her parents
very I mean they're divorced they had a
lot of issues um and you want to be
specific they
uh they did things that parents
shouldn't do uh with their children like
take them to bars at 2 am. and have the
six-year-old drive them home like uh
that's probably the most blatant example
um and just a lot of irresponsibility
and vilification of a relationship and
um I think that's affected her greatly
and we we've seen a counselor and that
came up but you know she wasn't able to
really delve into it um for whatever
reason she doesn't like talking about
herself or her own problems um so that's
kind of where we're at like I don't I
you know I've told her like we need to
be I agree I need to be stepping up in
the romance department but you know
there needs to be some give and take on
your end and she's like I just don't
enjoy it like I I don't want to be
touched down there and I don't wish to
it hurts and I don't enjoy it at all I
get nothing out of it I was like gez
well that sucks well and so here's a
couple of things that happen number one
men almost always take that very
personally yeah and they forecast it
into the next 20 years oh oh c because I
don't know any guy who wants to hurt his
wife right but also I don't know any guy
who wants to be married for 20 years and
not have sex I don't know any I don't
know women who I I mean I know they're
there I know there's there's all kinds
of of different um sexual appetites
right but very few people don't want to
be intimate for 20 years right and so
your challenge is to a not take this
personally it's not about like if you
are hotter or whatever or it's an insult
to you this is somebody saying hey it
hurts is is somebody saying there's a
lot of psychological baggage potentially
here I also can't
imagine that in this partic and and
let's just be super
clear if I sat down with her my guess is
it wouldn't only be going out in the
truck and looking at the
stars which is a proxy for or I just
want to be with you and you're like
that's cool let's do it and suddenly
this act of sex might become the thing
that she grows to
hate because she feels like you don't
listen to her you don't you don't care
about
her you you care about taking care of
your needs and she is the vehicle by
which you do that right who knows but I
think it's really important for her to
go see a doctor and figure out the pain
because I start thinking about PCOS I
start thinking about uh endometriosis uh
fibroids there's all kind of stuff going
on has she done
that um I don't think so like we she she
got checked she had a bunch of
concussions in high school and she got
checked like up and down but I don't
know that she got checked for that dude
here's how this here's how the
conversation goes she goes to her doctor
and says I hate
sex okay and the doctor says give me
some more information and I promise you
she's going to be more open with her
doctor than with you a you sound like
your head's filled with cement b um they
have a relationship especially with
OBGYN doctors delivered her babies
doctors walked her along through one
pregnancy now into the second one and so
they're going to have a different
conversation but it has to be that that
blunt she has to tell the truth to her
doctor gotcha and honestly if if this is
my wife this is my sister is my friend
this is where I would recommend you
start start with your with your
doctor okay the challenge is she might
look at you and say I don't want
to and that's hard that would be a hard
scary conversation to
have well she said that before I mean
when we went to counseling she she
didn't want to go because she doesn't
like talking about her feelings and you
know it's not a priority I mean we've
got another kid on the way
so there's that yeah it's it's super
super big time of priority sounds like
there honestly it sounds like there is a
lot going on and sex is one of the
lights on the dashboard telling you that
things aren't
okay well I mean overall we're we're
pretty happy I mean we we have a pretty
nice home we have good jobs dude bro you
are missing it like by 100 miles oh okay
like by a long shot there's a couple of
women listening to this right now and
they're both they're nodding their
heads oh well I mean what do you
mean I mean you are have a picture in
your head of we're doing fine which
means what's a dollar amount what's a
square footage amount what is a safety
amount what is a how many times a week I
exercise and she's going to tell you
doing okay is do you hear me
yeah and you're going to go ah look how
nice our house
is hey can we do this and this and this
and this
please let's just do
it hey this hurts like I don't like it I
hate it it hurts I don't want to talk
about my
feelings yeah you're going to go talk
about your feelings we got to do
this that sounds like somebody who is
screaming for somebody to give them a
safe space to
talk if you if you were like my close
buddy here's what I would tell you to do
I would tell you to take a knee and what
I mean by that is I would take my wife
out in the
truck in front of some stars and I would
hold her hand and I would
say after I talked to this podcaster I
realized I missed the boat and I haven't
heard you or seen you for all of our
marriage and I thought about getting
great jobs and I thought about mechanics
and I thought about
needs and for some reason I didn't hear
you I'm
sorry I want to have sex with you I want
to be intimate with you I want that to
be a an important part of our
relationship but beneath that I want you
to know I hear you and I see you and I
love you
anyway and my brother that's where you
got to
start because at some point one of you
going to lose your job at some point one
of you or both of you is going to quit
working and you're going to do something
else and you got to have a way stronger
Foundation than
that but try that and if if if it
doesn't go well call me back and say
you're an idiot
I took a knee in fromont my wife told
her I was sorry asked her what does she
need what does she want and I started
not doing any of the things in my
toolkit I started doing exactly what she
said started helping her with the home I
started helping with relationship stuff
I started holding her hand I started
doing these
things and then I asked her on behalf of
you behalf of our kids on behalf of me
would you go to the doctor and tell them
that you hate sex and that pain it's
painful it
hurts
would you do that please I love you that
much and I'm asking you to love me that
much let's see what happens
there take e
brother I have a sneaking suspicion that
um the whole concept around intimacy is
way way bigger than what's going on in
your bedroom right
now and let me ask add this if she won't
go to C counseling you can still
go cuz what you're doing is not working
let's try find some new
tools check out that book I'll link to
it in the show notes Come As You Are by
Dr Emily
nski um it is phenomenal it's a great
way to start a conversation in your
marriage we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's deloney what in the world
is going on listen this is that time of
year
Family Travel everyone telling you what
to do the end of the year fiscal season
money politics all of it and all of it's
happening in the dark because the sun
goes down and it doesn't seem to want to
come up Seasonal effective disorder is
real so you put Darkness on top of all
of it and wow it gets dark at 4:30 where
I live and I'm ready for bed at 5:45 in
the evening things aren't as fun
sometimes even my food tastes different
but now I know I got to take care of my
body I got to get outside even when it's
dark outside or even when it's early in
the morning I got to move my body I got
to put bright lights in my eyes and I
have to intentionally connect with
people and sometimes intentionally
connecting with people is about friends
and other times intentionally connecting
with people is with therapy therapy can
be a bright spot in the cha at the end
of the year even when the Sun goes down
too soon something to help you feel
positive and grounded and give you tools
to manage all this madness when nothing
else will so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online and it can fit into any
schedule you have just fill out a short
questionnaire you're going to get
matched with the licensed therapist and
you could switch therapist at any time
for no charge
find your bright spot in the chaos find
some peace When Everything feels like
it's spinning out of control with my
friends at betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com dealone today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com dealone you're worth
it all right let's go out to Louisville
Kentucky and or as America says
Lewisville and to ter what's up
Tera hey how are you good how are you
I'm okay I'm at work what's that F I
hope that's good sounds fantastic it's
good it's a fine all right so what's
up um I was calling about our
relationship with our son and his wife
um my question was how can we best
communicate with our son and his wife
that we still hurt and left out by them
always choosing her side of the family
over us we miss out on seeing our
granddaughter especially during the
holidays because they spend more time
with our daughter-in-law's family and
the multiple branches of her extended
family um I hate that our son feels
pulled both ways and I would never ask
him to choose us over his wife but I
feel that they don't divide the holidays
equally or fairly between our
families how how's that conversation
gone in the past um well it's been only
with our son generally because she
doesn't like
confrontation um oh boy this just sounds
gross let me ask you this yeah has your
husband taken your son
out for coffee or a drink or what
however they communicate and they may
not communicate at all but say hey ma'am
I miss you I miss my granddaughter is
there something I've done is there
something that we're doing to make
people feel uncomfortable because I miss
you guys
yeah there's been conversations both me
and him have had conversations with him
okay um we do get to see them some it
just seems like the holidays are um a
little one-sided you know we do we do
they live close so it's not like we
don't see them at all we do um she has
divorced parents and divorced
grandparents as well as a robust step
family through her stepmom and so there
is a lot going on with her you know
especially during the holidays um but
just this past Halloween we got kind of
left out in the cold and it really hurts
and that's not the first holiday has
happened and I don't look forward to the
rest of the holidays because of it
so have you
guys thrown a holiday party and invited
them and they just have shunned you and
said no they've never completely not
tried to come until Halloween this past
Halloween um usually we get five 10
minutes here there or we maybe get an
hour or we can squeeze you in for 30
minutes you know and they never have
time to do like the full event because
they've got three other things to do
before the day is over
with what do you think it
is
I you're smart I think she are y'all let
me are y'all a
lot or a lot I don't think so I don't
think she agrees with everything we
believe in politically or religiously
okay um but we don't force those things
on her while she's at her house um but
she you know she has opinions and we
respect
them okay we don't try to you know over
you know parent you know try to tell
them how to parent their child or
anything like that um I'm just worried
I'm getting kind of resentful you know
that I have to beg for time with from
for them with them both of them and her
and my granddaughter as well so You'
probably heard me say this on the show
and it's one of the most heartbreaking
things I can
say but behavior is a language so if
behavior is a language what are they
telling
you that they don't enjoy being with us
correct yeah and that they'd rather be
with other people no no no no that's you
adding your part to the story
yeah that's you adding that's adding
your little
dig the facts that you
know is that they have repeatedly told
you through their
actions we would rather not be
here and anything else you add to that
is you making up more to the
story and so with what you
have it's not your son's job or your
daughter-in-law's job to to fulfill
your invented picture about what
grandparenthood was going to look
like it is I
think especially your son his
responsibility to be an adult and to
have a hard conversation with his mom
and dad which he has refused to
do and I think it's fair to say I I I'm
assuming not now you can tell me no
you're wrong John but I'm assuming the
conversation has not taken place with um
your husband and
him off somewhere just them two over a
steak or
whatever hey like I just I just need to
know for my own
soul do we do something do we believe in
something do we make you all upset do we
make you mad do we hurt your wife what
happened
and your husband tell your son my
expectation dude is just be honest with
me just tell me the truth
yeah and I know you want to pitch in
there and you never let us do this and I
missed my granddaughter and I want I get
all that but I think that's what's led
to
this and maybe he has a very very
immature
wife
maybe but my wife has 5 b870 2 million
cousins and all kinds of
family and we
alternate just how we do
it we both love being with both
Crews that make
sense yeah I I agree um the husband and
the son have not probably sat down face
to face alone but there has been phone
conversations
cut not going to cut it and you all live
in the same Community CU here's what
usually happens you get upset and your
husband feels like he needs to take care
of you and he calls and says hey man
what's up can't come for 10 minutes and
your son goes all right Dad we'll be
there for 10
minutes oh we'll swing by and they swing
by for 10 minutes and they
leave is that about what happens yeah
probably probably I think your grown-up
husband needs to have a grown-up
conversation with his grownup
son um I mean I guess if boundaries are
needed I don't I I'm blind to those
issues if that's the case but I like to
know them probably that may be why
they're creating pretty firm ones
yeah and you may have said something
four years ago that you don't even
remember saying that set off something
in your daughter-in-law's heart and mind
mind and
body that she experienced and her family
got divorced and she made a commitment
that I'm not going to be a part of X Y
or Z and you may not even
know that's why I like the invitation
I'm going to be weird and I'm going to
go
first and if he says your son looks your
husband in the eye and says dad there's
nothing we got a lot of family to see
and so this is kind of how we do
it then you and your husband have to
grieve the ever loving crap out of this
cuz I just
stinks mhm and it is and then y'all can
choose um to just extract every second
of those 10 minutes you
get you can choose to send little videos
and write letters and have a on once a
month or once every two weeks we're
going to send a book to the
grandkids we are going to behavior as a
language we're going to act into this
little s deler of space we have to let
you know that we love you we love you we
love you and if your Mom and Dad don't
want us to see you you're never going to
not know that we don't love love you to
the moon in
back see what I'm saying Ian you can do
what what you can with what you
got yeah we've been doing that that's
awesome up until now yes awesome so what
happened to this particular thanksgiv I
mean I me Halloween that made you
upset um I asked the had time if they
would just stop by because I knew they
did probably already have plan to go
somewhere and he said yeah we'll stop by
for a few minutes I had a little goodie
bag and a little coloring book I had
bought for her and I wanted to see her
in her costume um you know and the
evening just you know flew by and they
never showed up and you know he text me
to say that she was cold and they went
ahead and went home you know and never
stopped by so um I don't just hurt I
don't see a problem with you taking your
son out for coffee saying hey that that
hurt I'm your mom's at least worth a
phone call to say that you're not coming
but I had stuff he tried to call he
tried to call but I was already crying
and upset and so I wasn't ready to talk
about everything why' you go
there um because this isn't the first
time and I mean there's always an excuse
you know there's all it's never the
truth I don't guess you know and why is
that a story you've made up potentially
made
up you think your son lies to you every
time no I don't I just don't think he
talks for her you know and I think he
tries to not hurt our
feelings okay does he have does he have
permission to hurt your
feelings for me has he ever had
permission to hurt your feelings as long
as he's been
alive now guess he needed permission he
can do it if he wants and he
has not really here's what I'm saying um
was it his job to make like like hey
don't do that or your dad's going to get
mad or hey pick that up your mother's
coming home no I don't think so
okay then it sounds like it sounds like
the adults in his life need to have
adult conversations hey honey I'd love
to take you out for dinner just you and
me and you can do that his his dad can
do that but I think this dancing around
the topic can you come by for 10 minutes
sure we'll be there you didn't come I'm
weeping hey Mom I'm trying to call I'm
not I can't take your call then
Thanksgiving comes around hey can y'all
swing by for a little bit just to have
some pie sure and then this
whole man just cut all that out just sit
down across the table adult to adult and
say hey I love you and I had this
picture in my mind that when you start
having kids we'd have this big time
together and I know your wife has a huge
family what have we
done what have we done what what have I
done have I made it hard and I'm a big
girl and you can tell me the like the
hard truth but it's not adding
up or say the say the thing I always say
behavior is a language and it's coming
through loud and clear you don't want to
be around
us and you're allowed to do that you're
an adult but it breaks my heart and like
what
happened I think you have to be that
clear and that direct and if he looks
you n and lies to you then that's your
answer
and I 100% know that's scarier than just
playing it the 10 minutes by 10 minutes
every couple of
months because there's a finality to
that potentially there's a vulnerability
to
it and he might say my wife is simply
uncomfortable with you and your politics
and your religious stuff she's
uncomfortable
and then you get to decide afraid go
ahead you're I afraid to completely lose
them yeah but now you're in resentment
you have lost
them you have lost him because you're
not grieving it you're just getting
madder and madder you're just simmering
and simmering and
simmering and your son would say Mom I
tried to call this thing happened my kid
was sick I went to go home and you
wouldn't take my call that would be if
he called my show right now that's what
he would say I tried to call my mom and
let her know she wouldn't even take my
call see how this just goes round and
round and round until somebody flips all
the lights on and says I'm I'm done with
this just let's sit down and talk yeah
no I agree we need Heart come to Jesus
meeting I guess is what you call it yeah
but it's not a come to Jesus cuz when I
I say when I think of comeing to Jesus I
think of like hey this is the way it's
going to be and I don't think that needs
to be this meeting this is a
truth-telling meeting this is a
vulnerable you could really hurt me
right now and I'd rather be hurt and
know the truth than just continue to do
this silly little
dance because the silly little dance is
just burning us both up he's getting
anxious every holiday season because he
feels like he has to display his kid on
a trophy however everybody in the world
wants to see his kid and you have
expectations his wife has expectations
his in-laws have expectations and
enough's enough's
enough that's why me and my wife started
sending an email out actually I'm behind
on that I need to get that out but we
started sending an email out to all of
our family here's what we're doing this
this holiday season we'd love for you to
be a part of it it might only be 24
hours this year it might be a week next
year whatever that looks like um but
here's what we're doing and then the
adults in our lives get to choose they
going to be upset they're going to be
happy they're going to be overjoyed
they're going to join us going to not
join us that's that's the choices
they're
making or my dad calls and says hey we
would really mean a lot to us if you did
this awesome we're going to try to
figure that
out but it's grown-up time talking to
grown-up
time no more dancing and by the way I'm
G strongly suggest you and your husband
don't do this
together because it's going to throw
your kids body back into when he was 9
years old and he got in trouble for
something and Mom and Dad sat on either
one of the chairs in the living room
kind of thing don't do that one of you
at a
time probably preferably dad but if Dad
just won't do it then Mom can do it too
and is not
aack it is not hey why have you been
that's not what we're doing here it is
man I had a different picture in my head
and I've clearly done something I'm
sorry but I miss you guys what happened
I'm I'm a I'm a grownup I can take it
but please tell me the
truth that's all choose real it and
start from there I hate this for you
Tera I hate it hate it hate
it but maybe if you go in with a posture
of humility and vulnerability you might
learn yeah Mom whenever we mention this
you say this and we just not going to be
around that anymore or yeah you make it
real uncomfortable with this this and
this maybe you'll hear that then you'll
have a opportunity to change or an
opportunity to say well that's just the
way I am and um that's my hope for you
guys let's start with calling it what it
is
let me know how that conversation goes
I'm going to be fascinated to hear how
this one wraps up we'll be right
[Music]
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days free
all right let's go out to as Texans call
it Southern Canada let's go out to
Oklahoma and talk to Tyler what's up
Tyler hey how are you just dancing Like
It's
1999 what's up that's awesome well yeah
I wrote my question down can I just read
it of course awesome so um yeah so
there's a group of parents there's about
five families from our kids school and
we spend a lot of time with them we do a
lot of baseball games you know baseball
practices School event and uh we started
hanging out with everyone outside of
that on like weekend trips uh birthday
dinners random outings and the girls do
dinner outings and uh the guys we all
play in like a softball league
together and uh you know we thought we
were in the group and we did all these
events together and we we were close
with everyone but we found out that uh
the rest of the group celebrated
someone's birthday in the group uh
without us and that stung pretty good
and when we asked about their evening
the next day at one of the kids games uh
the group wasn't quite honest with us
which hurt and uh you know we found out
that night on social media what was
going on and uh we thought we were close
with all these families but the Omission
made us really question it and so my
question is how do we build meaningful
relationships with these families that
goes beyond just you know doing these
random things that turns into a real
friendship you know we see a lot of
potential in them and ever since this
event it uh really I don't know started
making us question
everything yeah that stinks man to feel
like uh to be left out huh yeah it did
it hurt pretty good do you have a
guess um well we have a little bit of an
update I don't know if this is a guess
we started thinking about our you know
relationship with all of them and and
noticed that we there's a little bit of
a socioeconomic gap between us and them
and so I think we were embarrassed by
that and so we weren't inviting people
to go out you know one-on-one or like
double dates or anything like that for a
while and um since this event we just T
like talked uh my wife and I talked
about just getting over ourselves and
inviting them to our house even though
it's real small compared to them you
know things like that and we' started to
notice that's actually helped a little
bit and just um when we're around
everyone like leaning in and being extra
you know relational about you know
what's going on with their
life I think that what you just said is
really really
important and I think that type of
reflection is hard these days but I'm
proud of yall for doing that so if I
hear you right they do pretty well y'all
aren't at the same level as they
are and you all have some
self-consciousness about
it yeah there's that and we were burned
by some friends in the past and I think
there's a little bit of that too so want
how are you how are you burned in the
past um we had some real close friends
that um just started getting really
weird with the man's in the friend group
and then started just acting like not
great to one another a little bit of
backstabbing and so we we removed
ourselves from that friend group uh
through some time and and space and we
actually mov cities too so how didd you
get burned by
it um I think we were hurt with uh so
one of them um rented one of our houses
which was probably not the smartest
decision correct and um they they came
in you know we if we thought it would be
like wonderful and you know maintain the
friendship and then they slid one day at
dinner S A List of Demands on updates to
the house that they expected us to make
and then just started you know demanding
different things as tenants which yeah
hindsight is 2020 we probably wouldn't
do that again
um yeah you made a friend you allowed a
friendship to turn into a business
transaction yeah yeah that's tough um
yeah I often push back sometimes I get a
lot of flak for it and that's fine I
think it's not wise to be best buddies
with the person who pay writes your
paycheck oh yeah I think we learned that
we won't do that again right here's what
I'm hearing a pattern of you
guys weit into
something and then you just get
hurt hurts our feelings hurts our
feelings hurts our
feelings and it sounds like you guys
made probably not the wisest move by
allowing some friends to move into a
house that needed some work done on it
and maybe your friends were a little
over the top with their
requests but my guess is once they made
those requests you were like yeah that's
for sure my that that friend of ours
like of course they would do that to
anybody we knew that like now that we
see it we're like oh yeah that's how
they would do that to any landlord it
wasn't his personal and they probably
were they probably were
like dude like
the they got to do these of course they
got to do these things you see what I'm
saying and then you have new friends
that you're like well we're kind of
embarrassed because our house is
small like I I and they might have all
got together and been like hey let's
just we're we're trying we're trying to
help yall out we don't embarrass y'all
because they clearly see what I'm saying
yeah totally I think there's something
about a going Reckless all
in and Reckless all in I don't who cares
how big your house is and then I've got
that's kind of where we're at now we're
just we don't know how to take it to
that next step after that like if we go
all Reckless like what does that look
like it feels like dating without a
guide book only if you're doing this for
Roi
purposes I hang out with my friends cuz
I like my
friends like I don't I don't have a
reference point for like how many times
and are they doing this without us and
what about this I expect my friends to
have other
friends and I'm not dating them so like
if I when I was exclusive with my wife
if she was going out with other boys I
would be like hey what's the deal but
she didn't do that I don't have that
same expectation for my adult friends I
just firmly expect my adult friends
especially my new ones to have friends
with other adults oh totally yeah and I
think we acknowledge that and I think
yeah I think we just want to know just
how to build meaningful relationship not
not for an RO invite people
over yeah and just keep getting over
just continue to lean into that yeah I I
mean nothing you've told me sounds weird
it sounds like a group of people of mean
said hey we want to do birthday party X
we don't want them to feel weird because
they clearly don't want us around they
don't even have us to their house they
don't come to things whenever we're
going on double dates whatever let's
just do this together and it sounds like
they might have been trying to do it to
help yall out because they don't want to
make yall feel awkward yeah sure I think
that's what we started telling ourselves
the positive narrative how you spun it
and then in inviting them in it's gotten
a lot like we feel like the
relationships are even better and like
we're closer with people and enjoy like
they enjoyed being at our house you know
we enjoy being around them and we've
even done more stuff on the weekend
since leaning in I think that initial
hurt and just not being honest with us
you know it just hurt it you know it
hurts finding to Stu out like that yeah
I
mean I get I mean I get I get I guess I
I get that um I think you'll have some
pretty firm expectations some high
expectations especially being a new
group to a new town with some
potentially established
friendships
um and also holding it with an open hand
we all we all came together at the same
time so and we've been we've been
hanging out for about three years right
at the start of Co okay yeah I I mean I
I just dude I wouldn't overthink it and
I've I've got some new friends that I
made here in my town in my rural
community they're amazing David Ricky
some of these guys are incredible
they're awesome and they get together
once a month or something to play uh
like is it Dungeons and Dragons some
cart some game
right they've never one time asked hey
would you like to come over and play
this this game with
us I think they just kind of know it's
not really my jam they get together dude
they get snacks they stay up all night
it's this whole thing they're inviting
their boys in not one time have I ever
been invited and would I like to be
invited that'd be awesome would I ever
go never right and they know that and so
like I'm so excited that my friends have
this weird thing they
do and I've never invited them to heavy
metal band practice
I don't even know if they can play
instruments see what I'm saying like I I
I would take the hurt and the D the the
the the dating language kind of out of
it I mean it's cool to be like man honey
I wish they we got invited to birthday
party yeah we need to make sure we
invite everybody when we do it I'm kind
of moving on my day I'm not going to
give them that you know what I mean oh
totally that makes total sense yeah and
then like you mentioned when you start
opening up
that's why people always ask me how do I
make friends I always say you go first
and you be
weird cuz waiting for somebody else to
go first or waiting for somebody else to
invite you waiting for somebody else to
be vulnerable first then it's just this
weird you know Dosey Do here we go like
uh prominade your partner on the old oak
tree kind of like everyone's just
dancing around the reality and so it's
something else when you invite somebody
over like this is my house this how we
roll and yeah that makes total sense I
think yeah I think that we've realized
that we were closed off and potentially
it was on our shoulders for not uh being
open first and so yeah we leaning in
that's I I would just keep being weird
dude I'd keep being weird I'd keep being
weird and if a group of friends decides
quietly they don't want you around you
can do one of two things you can say hey
man I know this yall like a lot of stuff
been going on you don't invite me have I
made this weird or am I awkward or
something and they might say yeah dude
like like here's the X and the Y and the
Z or they might say no dude we just want
to be like we we know every time we go
out you guys don't either don't eat or
we don't want to make it
weird um or our kids have more in common
with X or with Y I see that happen a lot
too that the kids say hey our kid
doesn't want to hang out with these kid
and so the parents kind of drift that
way
too it could be any number of things at
the end of the day of course grieve it
man we thought these were our friends
and they're not or we thought these were
our friends and they lied to us that
sucks and then we're going to be about
grieving it and then moving on to what's
next but it sounds like you guys have a
pattern of having expectations about a
relationship that the other party
doesn't have and then getting as you say
hurt when those expectations aren't met
across the board and so I'd either be
super clear about my expectations or
dude just kind of loosen your grip on it
a little bit y'all aren't dating these
are just grownup friends navigating a
whole like work and family and and kids
all of it all the sports all of it all
together hold it with some empty hands
my guess is you're going to start
spending more and more time with people
um fewer and fewer people those
relationships are going to get Tighter
and Tighter and Tighter be awesome hang
in there brother appreciate you we'll be
right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else in the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John
del. all right we are back and it's time
for this week's am I the problem it's me
or is it the name of the segment changes
every time yeah we haven't quite landed
that plane just yet oh we crash blades
on this show all right let's do it here
we go my mother-in-law has never liked
me and treats me very different than her
other daughter-in-law I put up with it
for about two years and played nice four
years in now and I'm at the point where
I'm done playing
nice now she just like nice it's like
I'm I'm Joanna Wick
I don't go over to see her I don't
strike up conversations at family
gatherings I just pretend she's not
there well she seems to feel guilty now
and is pretending to be nice to me
coming over and bringing me treats and
trying to pretend we're friends am I the
problem for not trusting her and letting
her
in I think this person is the problem
for even sending this email yes she's
the
problem I think she's the problem here's
why here's
why if somebody's in your opinion is
acting like a
child and your response is
to act like double the
child then you have brought your
immaturity to an immature
situation and then the narrative you're
making up about this other person and
then I guess cuz she feels bad now she's
bringing these treats to protect that
you have no idea have no
idea I would love to unpack like how do
you know that she was treating like be
very specific about how she was clearly
treating this other sister-in-law better
than you how you clearly know she loves
her more than you
and how you showed her I'm just going to
pretend you're not there that is a sixth
grader that's like a mature adult would
say hey can we go to
coffee have I made you upset like I have
this picture of how this was was going
to be and
I at least give her an opportunity to to
lie to your face or to get mad or
whatever I almost never see that
happening I almost always see it like oh
God I had no I no clue I wanted to like
protect your space I wanted to love you
the best way I can't oh my gosh I'm so
sorry and it sounds like mother-in-law
is like oh
crap she my my daughter-in-law doesn't
even like me like I'm GNA use the tools
I got in my toolkit gifts showing up
being extra kind and then it's just as
beray Brown says what you go looking for
the world you're going to find that that
mother-in-law cannot win she can
continue to ignore and she'll go see she
can be really kind and she'll go see she
can bring her gifts and she'll go see
there's no mother-in-law there's nothing
she can do so I'm I'm team otherw on
this one you disagree so what do you
think no I don't disagree I think that
it's possibly that it's just two
immature people that maybe they both are
the problem but you can see that but we
don't know that because we don't know
the mother-in-laws we don't know the
like you said there was no specifics but
I think there needs to be a conversation
yes and you know maybe she is maybe it's
like oh well I've known other sister you
know they they've been dating since
middle school or whatever and I've just
known them forever and I don't like you
she's a nurse and I've been struggling
with hemorrhoids you didn't even know it
and we talk about sorry I know I didn't
mean to I have a struggle with with her
toenails and she helps me out with like
you never know right but like if
somebody calls and says I did a really
immature thing in the face of another
immature thing am I the problem I'm
always going to say yes right because
instead of bringing bring you came down
to it correct yeah so bring maturity to
immature situations let somebody clearly
State and I'll say this a thousand times
and I I've said thousand times say a
thousand times more get out of other
people's heads you don't know why
they're doing what they're
doing if you have to live in that world
where you're creating stories about
other people at least give them the
opportunity by you acting like a mature
adult putting it on the table and saying
you tell me is this
true
like really do you not like me I don't
know I just don't think that's weird or
hard no but it's rarely done but as my
wife says John you're very awkward and
you always have been so maybe that's
just it I don't know who do you think's
the problem I think it's definitely the
daughter-in-law but I think there just
needs to be a conversation
that neither of them are willing to have
or going to have or the big question is
why did you send this
in no everybody thinks their
mother-in-law is a narcissist based on
the emails that we get on this
show every mother-in-law ever of all
time except Mine mine's awesome but alas
oh yours is too Kelly my mother-in-law
was phenomenal yeah it's amazing all
right we love you all stay in school
don't bring immaturity to an immature
world we don't we've got we got plenty
of it bring grown upness
bye